[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes la famille est le
lieu privilégié de l'apprentissage de ce
qui permettra à l'enfant d'aujourd'hui
d'être l'adulte de demain
c'est pourquoi je propose une politique
familiale forte fondée sur cinq
engagements
je m'engage à créer une allocation
parentale de libre choix d'un montant de
trois quarts du smic pour que le parent
qui le souhaitent puissent se consacrer
à l'éducation de ses enfants pendant les
premières années de leur vie
et cette allocation ouvrira également
des droits à la retraite
je m'engage à initier un pacte de
responsabilité entre les familles les
médias et les pouvoirs publics pour
limiter la diffusion des images
violentes et dire non à la pornographie
je m'engage à interdire l'adoption
homosexuelle et à faire valoir le droit
de chaque enfant à être élevé par un
père et une mère
je m'engage à respecter le libre choix
de l'école par les parents et à garantir
à toute femme enceinte en difficulté les
moyens matériels et la nécessaire pour
accueillir la vie un ministère d'état de
la famille garantira le respect de la
famille par toute décision publique
ainsi la politique familiale deviendra
le fondement le socle de toute la
politique d'avenir pour la prospérité de
la france
à bientôt
[Musique]